a grand jury report about the sex abuse
of children by priests in Pennsylvania
was released yesterday over 300 predator
priests are named in the document the
specifics are graphic and horrifying
they do involve of course violence
sexual assault and rape and sometimes
the coordinated abuse of children by
multiple priests in the same parish and
of course the opportunity for abuse as
we have seen in so many other cases was
furnished by bishops and other church
officials who either look the other way
or actively helped to cover up the
crimes now I want to mention just a few
specific details from this report of
specific crimes that occurred against
children and of course I should warn you
that these details are extremely
extremely disturbing and graphic and
certainly not suitable to listen to if
you have kids in the room right now so
if that's the case then turn off the
video or the podcast come back to it
later but I do think that we should look
at a few of these examples just so we
understand how evil this is all right
in one case a boy was forced to stand
naked posing like Christ on the cross
while priests took pictures of him and
added them to a collection of child
pornography that they produced and
distributed on the campus of the church
it quite literally sounds like something
from a horror movie
it sounds like something from it sounds
made-up it sounds fictional but it's not
but it gets worse
um these priests would actually mark
boys were being groomed for abuse and
who are desensitized to abuse and thus
are easier to abuse they would mark them
so that other predator priests wouldn't
know and could then abuse them as well
and the way that they would mark them is
that they would give these boys a gift
of a gold crucifix to weigh around their
necks and if other predator priests saw
that gold crucifix around the necks of a
boy they knew that that he would be
vulnerable to abuse
in another case a priest raped a young
girl and then arranged for her to get an
abortion and his bishop heard about the
situation and wrote a letter of
condolence to the priest
who would rape the girl
another case a priest molested a boy
over the course of a couple of years he
admitted
church officials that that he had
engaged in naked quote horseplay with
the boy and yet he wasn't he was sent
for treatment for a few months and then
he was allowed to continue in ministry
for seven more years in another case a
priest raped a little girl while he was
visiting her in the hospital after she
had gotten her tonsils removed he
visited her in the hospital and raped
her in another case a a priest forced a
boy to give him oral sex and then
afterwards washed the boy's mouth out
with holy water
to quote purify him in another case a
priest molested a twelve-year-old boy
admitted his crime to a church official
but the diocese ruled that the abuse
wouldn't quote necessarily be a
horrendous trauma to the victim and so
they didn't do anything else
and on and on and on they're over there
are over a thousand victims in this
report so there are many more cases like
this but I just I physically can't read
any more than that and I doubt you could
physically listen to any more than that
the point that I'm trying to get to here
and I think you understand that this is
demonic straight up
this is Satanism what else can you call
it
there is a virus in the Catholic Church
and it has to be rooted out and crushed
there has to be a purge in the church
and I don't think that purge has really
happened yet I think very clearly it has
not and I don't see any way for this
purge to happen unless it is ruthless
and brutal and uncompromising if we have
to err on the side of of being merciless
or being tolerant that I think we need
to err on the side of being merciless
every time when it comes to this
now unfortunately the laws in our
country won't allow us to take these
priests and hang them which which they
so richly deserve
even less will allow us will it allow us
to burn them at the stake which I think
would be poetic in many ways but we
can't do that but we can't expose them
we can shame them rebuke them and
hopefully they can be locked in cages
for the rest of their mortal lives so
you know I think Catholics are tempted
to believe that the scandals are kind of
behind us and that that was then this is
now
but the Cardinal McCarrick case which is
just coming out in the last few weeks
and now this in Pennsylvania I think
they clearly show that this is not
behind us the cancer has not been
completely removed and what happens when
you don't completely remove a cancer it
grows back so it must be completely
totally removed it has not been
and I think when you see the reluctance
of most priests and bishops to come
forward even now and speak passionately
and publicly against these crimes that
yet again shows that the problem is not
in the past because the Predators and
the cowards who aid and abet them remain
so that's one thing you know the average
Catholic goes to church they're not
necessarily gonna know if they're if
abuse is going on they can't it's not
something they can see for themselves
obviously but they can see moral
cowardice among their leaders and there
is a lot of it a lot in the American
church
they can see that and I think it's a
pretty safe bet as long as the church is
infected by these
spineless gutless cowards as long as
they are there the Predators will remain
as well because that is the environment
in which the Predators thrive so what
can be done to root out this problem
well there are there are many steps that
can and should be taken I want to focus
on just three of them right now okay
the first step as I've already argued
and I'll argue again homosexuals must be
banned from the priesthood no exception
they must be banned
I said this has to be ruthless brutal
uncompromising and so that's one of
those steps every homosexual priests
band now I know that not every victim in
Pennsylvania was a boy I even mentioned
a few cases where where girls were
abused but most of the victims were AB
or boys and across the country over the
last several decades a vast majority of
in boys I've written in other places
that the most reliable study that's been
done on this has shown that over 80% of
the victims over 80% or boys which means
that a vast majority of the Predators
are males attracted to other males now
you can if you want you can come back
with with silliness about how men who
molest boys aren't gay but I don't think
that claim even warrants a response
because it is so idiotic
it is so contemptible and it is
contemptible because the person who
makes that claim knows what they're
saying is stupid yet they make it anyway
in an effort to prevent measures that
could protect children from being raped
and so that's why they're saying this is
these are people who care more about
protecting the the LGBT community than
they do about stopping children from
being raped and there are a lot of
people out there like that and every
single person right now who might be
trying to make a comment in the comment
section saying something well just
because a man molest a boy that doesn't
mean he's gay you that's stupid that's
idiotic it's contemptible you know it
you know what you're saying makes no
sense you you damn well know that a man
who goes after a boy is gay if a man is
not gay he's not gonna be a tree he's
not gonna be going after boys this is a
very simple equation there's no getting
around it it's very simple
do I think that every homosexual is a
child molester No
but here's the thing we often Durst and
most child molesters in the church are
gay the vast majority are gay
that's a fact that's not my claim that's
not my argument that's not my duction
that's just empirically proven fact
the only question now is whether or not
we will do something about
we have to understand the problem of
homosexuals in the church goes goes
beyond the abusers this is as I say in
environment a culture that has been
constructed there is an actual
conspiracy in the church among
homosexual priests and bishops a
conspiracy this is not the stuff of
Hollywood this is real this is this is
actual conspiracy those who if you
haven't read into this if you're not
paying attention then you might not know
this but anyone who has read about it
and has paid attention knows that this
is the case
the homosexuals in the priesthood
conspire with each other to intimidate
and blackmail others into silence that's
what they do and as I just meant as I
just read one example of it
they even conspire with each other to
coordinate their abuse of boys
now just for an example for an
illustration of this
there was a sermon delivered by a father
Edwin palca at a church in Florida a few
weeks ago and this man father palco is
one of the good and courageous priests
and as a courageous priest he is I fear
in a very small minority in the American
church but he actually got up in front
of this congregation a few weeks ago and
I have this sermon because they posted
it in the bulletin in their church
bulletin which was then put online he
got up in front of his congregation and
apparently he's been doing a cert a
series of sermons on this but he
explained how this works
and how the actively homosexual priests
and bishops operate now I want to read
just the first couple of paragraphs of
this to set it up and then I'll
summarize the rest of it but um so
here's here's a little bit of what he
said he said one question that was asked
after last week's homily was why don't
good priests and good bishops blow the
whistle on the abuse of priests and
bishops many people still don't and I
believe most priests still don't
understand just how evil the act of
homosexual or homosexual activist
priests and bishops are not
understanding the extent of their
depravity and wrongly thinking that they
are simply normal men who just struggle
with their sexual desires and sometimes
might fail to remain chaste but are
really truly repentant when it happens
and strive to confess their sins and do
penance they cannot possibly grasp the
hellish depths to which the active
homosexual clergy will go to persecute
lambaste
punish humiliate and blackmail anyone
who stands in their way or threatens
their way of life let me be clear
the act of homosexual priests and
bishops treat their sexual mortal sin as
if it is a good and a god-given good at
that if they even believe in God
something of which I am very doubtful at
least in the Catholic understanding of
who God is nay more than a good they are
convinced that it is the good to be able
go to any repeat any lengths to force
others to engage in it to accept it or
to at the very least ignore it and
pretend that it doesn't exist
or that's not harmful enough to mention
or try to eradicate they do not struggle
with their disordered sexual desires as
so many others do but rather rather they
revel in them with that as my premise
let me explain why few good priests and
bishops will openly challenge their
brother priests and bishops when it
comes to this particular sin and I won't
read the rest of it verbatim but he
explains explains he gives just one
example of how this happens
he explains
that's when when men entered the
seminary as part of this process they
are asked to reveal a lot of very
personal information about themselves
which makes sense
it makes sense that in this this is this
is one thing the church should be doing
it's like we need to know about this man
who's coming in and wants to be a priest
and especially because he's about to
take us but he's about to take on a huge
amount of responsibility is going to be
sacrificing quite a bit theoretically
and so they need to know about so he
tells him a lot about their information
a lot of information about about about
themselves and this information is kept
in a file now ostensibly that file is is
there for a good reason so that he can
be you know so that his superiors can
can help him and guide him and they know
what he struggles with so they can kind
of look out for him that's the idea
behind this file and that file can grow
as he continues to struggle with things
and he makes mistakes and whatever
things end up in the file well
now you see how what can obviously
happen here now there is a file of very
personal information about this man and
the homosexual priests and bishops can
use that file to blackmail him
what's more he gives one
basically theoretical example but an
example of that represents things that
actually happens so he mentions one
thing that that the active homosexual
bishops can do to use this file against
the priest he mentions okay well fact
let me just read it he says suppose a
priest file reveals that as a team he
was sexually abused by an adult male as
a result of this formative abuse he
struggled with homosexual desires as an
adolescent and into his early adulthood
but always remain chaste
once ordained as a priest he spoke out
fervently against the acceptance and
promotion and legalization of homosexual
activity and other sexual sins his
active homosexual bishop knowing his
past makes him the Boy Scout chaplain
where who he will be working closely
with the bishops hand-picked and openly
active homosexual a diocesan Scout
leaders hoping and even encouraging him
to finally fall to his boyhood abuse
induced homosexual desires and sexually
abuse one or more of the scouts
while a continual perpetuation of this
sin is most greatly desired by the
homosexual bishop even one close call is
enough for a lifetime of blackmail so
you see what happens they know the the
the darkest secrets of these priests so
they can use that against them to try to
induce them into sin so they can then
use it against them
this is a priest getting up in front of
his congregation and revealing this he
has nothing let me just tell you he has
nothing to gain by saying this nothing
at all he is putting everything on the
line by segments so there is no reason
to doubt him whatsoever he has risked
quite a bit and this is in line with
what other priests have in moments of
candor said whether anonymously are
speaking out publicly which rarely
happens but when they do and they and
they're they're honest about it these
are the kinds of stories where there was
an uh there's another example maybe it
was from this priest or another that I
recently heard where priests who are
actively gay and who have abused boys
they will seek out heterosexual priests
for confession
and so they'll go even though they're
not rip they're not they're not they're
not really repenting at all but they'll
go to confession and they will tell all
of their horrible crimes to this
heterosexual priest knowing and the only
reason they do it is so that they know
that now that priest can't go and tell
anyone because according to church law
there is a seal in the confessional and
whatever you say in the confessional the
other the PERT the priest cannot ever
repeat it to anyone which is a rule that
of course makes a lot of sense otherwise
nobody would ever go to confession but
these homosexual priests will use that
they will use it like a weapon to seal
other priests into silence so these are
the kinds of things that happen again is
just demonic number two what else can be
done
the good priests and bishops
to come out and rebuke with righteous
fury okay they have to be heroes like
like father palca
and even with and it's understood now
that some of them are being blackmailed
they're being pressured that you know
horrible things are happening but still
they need to come out like father palca
and and and be heroes be courageous even
if it means they're going to be
personally destroyed because their own
secrets are going to come out
at a certain point you got to do the
right thing
and you know it these various bishops
who have issued statements about how sad
they are how grief-stricken that's not
gonna do Cardinal Wuerl who was who was
Bishop in Pittsburgh while these things
were happening and his guilty of
cover-ups himself he came out with a
very limp wristed kind of lament about
the tragedy of sexual abuse but no this
is not a tragedy it is a wickedness
straight from the pit of hell that's
what it is it's not just a tragedy it is
it is wickedness from hell and that's
what needs to be said we don't want to
hear about tragedies anymore we don't
want to hear about your sadness we want
you to we want to hear you call down the
wrath of God on the perpetrators that's
what we want to hear we want to hear
fire and brimstone
we want you to show us if you're if
you're a priest or a bishop we want you
to show us that you are disgusted and
enraged
why what's going on
or elsewill suspect that you don't care
or worse
I mean I just don't if you're a priest
what how could you even how could you do
anything but get up there on Sunday at
the pulpit and just rail against this as
I say fire and brimstone righteous anger
that's what's needed now nothing else
will do nothing else is going to solve
it and we have to name names because for
every priest who raped a boy there could
well be at least one more priest who
knew about it and remain silent and
those priests are guilty as well I'd say
they're as guilty as the actual rapist
because cowardice is a moral evil and
there has been quite a lot of that kind
of evil and that is the evil that as I
said that is the evil which creates kind
of the foundation and the environment
and the structure upon which these other
things happen
third thing last thing the laypeople in
the church
to start to use the power that they have
and they do have power they have power
because they have money so churches that
have been involved in abuse and coverup
must be starved of money by the
parishioners unless and until the church
can come forward beg for forgiveness
rebuke those who committed those sins in
those acts and rebuked them convincingly
and then clearly outline what steps they
have taken to rectify the problem there
has to be full transparency and full
accountability
any church that will not be fully
transparent and fully accountable when
it comes to this issue deserves to die
and the faithful will just have to drive
a bit further to a different church so I
think those are three steps that can and
should be taken I'm under no illusion
that any of them actually will be taken
but
they need to be and if they are not then
I don't
I don't see how this problem gets solved
thanks for listening everybody thanks
for watching
god speed